hi I'm Brad the foodie and I'm a food
blogger based on my favorite and today
I'm gonna bring you to my favorite spot
eat let's go
so Fritz is a french fry parlour and
they serve a lot of toppings where the
routines and a lot of selections for the
sauces for the fries and the routines
not too salty and it's perfectly crispy
[Music]
Daffy Duck is a hotdog place as a
Japanese twist on it and it's a really
popular spot in Vancouver and it serves
really delicious hot dogs that are
steaming hot and it also is a really
popular spot for our to go meals
[Music]
Oh
okie-dokie is a pokey shop and they
serve their pokey in a ball
[Music]
ethan is a publicly chain that sells
freaky MLP and they're really famous for
their black sugar pearl look and black
sugar pearl lattes the boba is super
super chewy and soft and super delicious
because you can't really taste the
roasted sugar flavor inside the milk
[Music]
smelly related the Korean visit store
and I felt a dice sí aquí
[Music]
and the techies are made with Shawn
ministries so they superflee
[Music]
so if your brain is a bakery store that
sells a lot of selection of pastries as
huge and affordable and it's super tasty
[Music]
so it's coming to the maritime in
Vancouver and is actually one of my
favorite room and places in town and I
always bring my friends here
[Music]
definitely find that a lot of
environment places after you finish
eating it you feel kind of that because
it's two of it for this one is still
equally rich and creamy but it still
it's quite light so you feel good
afterwards you have to try the egg it's
marinated on the outside but it's also
marinated it in the inside so you can
taste the soy sauce flavor in the yogurt
[Music]
you
[Music]